da aber kennt weder hass noch für den
80-jährigen geotope da ist noch lange
nicht schluss mit lustig von der jungen
generation heißt es ja sie habe keinen
sex mehr in japan nennt man sie
vegetarier oder so weil sie keine
fleischige lust mehr verspüren
mir macht es mut da sich auch im alter
noch gebraucht werde
deshalb gebe ich mir mühe und versuche
in form zu bleiben toko da ist kein
vegetarier und damit beileibe kein
einzelfall in japan hier wohl jeder
vierte über 65 jahre alt ist heißen die
senioren schon die generation server sex
eine zahlungskräftige klientel für
erotisches partneragenturen und dating
plattformen für ältere semester
florieren einchecken zur single
vermittlung im seniorenclub
10.000 mitglieder hat er hier flirten
200 die lebenserwartung steigt die
senioren sind gesund fit und aktiv beim
sex oft ganz unverbindlich
auch bei meinen freunden und die sind
alle ende 70 japan ist ein land der
widersprüche auch bei moralvorstellungen
und leiblichen freuden schmusen oder
auch bloß händchenhalten in der
öffentlichkeit ist verpönt
privat aber fallen die hemmungen ich mag
sex und gehalten arbeit und rom fahren
mit meinem sportwagen wenn es heute
klappt geht zuerst ins café und dann ab
ins hotel
ich möchte gar keine ehe lieber eine
unverbindliche partnerschaft einen
freund mit dem ich eine schöne zeit
haben kann gehen meine verheirateten
freundinnen beneiden mich um meine
freiheit in japan haben sex filme mit
älteren für ältere hochkonjunktur dieser
erotik boom ist mittlerweile zum
milliardengeschäft geworden
wer jenseits der rente noch daheim das
feuer schüren möchte für den gibt es
diesen video dauerbrenner mit wichtigen
tipps tricks und techniken für die
zweiten flitterwochen und alles noch
viel detaillierter als wie es hier je zu
zeigen warten
[Musik]
in japan sind ein drittel der frauen und
die hälfte aller männer unter 34 jahren
unverheiratet
der großteil führt auch keine
liebesbeziehung
ein grund ist der arbeitsmarkt der
vielen jungen kaum noch sicherheit und
freizeit bietet die retter hingegen
haben zeit und wenig schon an der single
börse streben sie zum höhepunkt dem
speed dating
das kann zuweilen sonnabend sein wer
einen favoriten hat hinterlegt den namen
bei moderator herrscht gegenseitige
sympathie werden die pärchen
rausgewunken
frau makita steht hoch im kurs gut dass
sich jemand passenden gefunden habe
nachher gehen wir ins café auch härter
fackelt nicht lange schon redet er vom
gemeinsamen bade besuch und ins hotel
will er ja auch noch unser rüstiger
senior toko da treibt es derweil auf die
spitze er ist pornostar den willkommenen
renten zustupf verheimlicht er zuhause
freilich lieber meine frau weiß nicht so
genau was ich hier machen er glaube ich
jedenfalls
ich sage immer dass ich als statist
auftreten auch in erwachsenenfilmen ist
und sie sagten du bist nicht mehr der
jüngste
ja sage ich du hast ja recht
es ist sinnlos darüber zu steigen das
würde die situation ja auch nicht
verbessern
in der boombranche alters erotik bedient
talk oder das reifere publikum regisseur
henry zucker motor selbst 72 versetzt
den zuschauer im film nicht zufällig in
die zeit nach dem zweiten weltkrieg nach
damals gab es nicht mal genug zu essen
aber die menschen haben überlebt
diese leute sind heute noch hängig auch
auf 6 sie sind lebens- und lebensfroh
ist er ist auch sexuell noch aktiv
freude an der erotik auch im alter ein
reizvolles motto
man muss ihn ja nicht gleich als
pornostar nach leben schön was hier an
der frischen luft heute auch wenn sich
das geheimnis des golfens mir noch nicht
ganz erschlossen hat ich behalte fürs
erste die wanderschuhe noch an
aber was soll so jung sehen wir uns nie
wieder bin aber trotzdem froh wenn sie